we we don't know too much about
uh rubius about your your training so
you're working with anna rudolph right
and uh
and ray dama the uh spanish speaking
channel
how's your chess beyond that like how
much chess have you played because you
were
amazing i mean we don't know much about
you so
i'm amazing now i've i started playing
like uh
three months ago or something like that
like and it was also
not because of queen's gambit but it was
uh because the
the previous spock times where xqc
failed in six moves
after that i began watching more
more test streams and it was thanks to
excuse and hikaru so yeah
sweet i don't remember that six moves
i don't know what you're talking about
yeah with moisture critical it was
amazing
oh yeah um yeah about that